(upbeat music)
- Honey, dig faster.
- Wanna help here?
- Whose house is this?
- I grew up here.
- Oh, your parents
still live here?
- No, I don't even know
who lives here anymore.
- Hey, son.
- Oh, wait, yeah,
that is my dad.
- Oh.
- We'll, we'll be right back.
C'mon, sweet, let's go.
- Who are you?
- What are all these
other gravestones?
- Pets don't live forever, Adam.
Wouldn't we all be
incredibly lucky
if our beloved pets
could live for two years?
- Might as well
cancel the funeral.
That dog is too
big for that hole.
- Ryan!
Your voice sounds perfect today!
I wouldn't be too sad if we
started off the whole thing
with a little song from you!
- I can't.
I've never sang before.
- Oh, come on, get in
the saddle, you puppy!
- Do it! Come on, please!
- All right.
♪ Deep river
- Holy fuck.
♪ I want to cross over Jordan
It almost makes me happy my
dog died so I can hear this.
- I know this song
perfectly, should I join him?
♪ Deep river
- Go sing!
- You can do it!
- I'm about to sing!
- He's about to!
- Please.
- Sing, sing!
♪ I want to cross
over into campground
- Here's the rhythm! (claps)
- I know this song so perfectly!
- Go go go go go!
(applause)
- I finished singing.
Thank you.
- Gorgeous baritone.
Ryan?
- Win or die.
I'm smarter than this
dog, and I proved that.
I proved that to all of you.
- Adam, go ahead.
Take as much time as you want.
- Okay.
I'd just like to say thanks
to everybody, especially Zach.
- Bamp! Boring alert! Time's up.
Women! Come on!
- Let's go, that's us.
- I had a whole
thing planned out.
- Actually, you know what,
you're really turning out
to be one of my top
guys, so watch out.
(sobbing)
(keening)
- I think what my new friend
Sarah is trying to say is
that in accepting
the gift of life--
(yawns loudly)
(claps slowly)
- Now my speech!
We've been brought together
by our love of book,
of learning, more than most.
I want you to think
of this dog's life
as a book that we all read.
- Not a very good book.
- No, not a very
good book at all.
In fact, most of it was
written like a shit.
- Yes, a stupid book.
It's a children's book,
I wish I'd never read it!
- But we read it
because we had to.
- Zach, Zach, pick me, pick me!
I think it's important to
not die with any secrets.
Who knows what this little
guy witnessed, or maybe saw?
And with that in mind, I
think you should all know
that I'm (mutters gibberish)
- What?
- I'm sexually attracted
to every one of you.
- Pete, this is not the
time nor the place, okay?
I'm speeching some very
inspiring stuff right now.
I want y'all to think,
remember, there are always kids
and autistic kids who go
to jail if they speak.
They get like
completely murdered
for uttering even a single word.
And that word
is hope.
So count your blessings, folks.
Coulda been us in that hole.
- Especially if we didn't win
the chocolate eating contest.
- A chocolate... You ate
chocolate with the dog?
- Yeah, that... I'm
smarter than that dog
'cause I won a chocolate
eating contest with it.
(sobs)
(groans)
♪ Deep--
- Bamp!
(drum music)
(water bubbling)